pas
de meilleur espoir féminin est attribué
à adele exarque au colosse appartenait à
ses douleurs les accords à bientôt
chiche la palme d'or à cannes on l'a
fait ses débuts au cinéma 11 ans d'un
dock 6 de jane birkin elle a aussi
vidant les enfants de timpelbach nicolas
bary tête de turc de pascal elbé
chez gino de samuel benchetrit doublé en
2013 dans des morceaux de moins d'une
heure wayne le mail elle tournera cette
année m
sous la direction de sara forestier bon
mais ce soir qui fera ses débuts en tant
que réalisatrice
c'est le premier césar de la soirée
pour les films dalglish l'avis d'appel
ah oui quand même
babel tu me manques je comprends
pourquoi t'es pas venu j'ai pas osé mais
ce césar je le dois
et oui abdel changé ma vie et c'est
grâce à toi que je suis ici merci de
m'avoir donné ma chance et est un des
rares réalisateurs français qui prend du
sang neuf comme nous donc merci les as
tu es ma plus belle histoire d'amour au
cinéma
merci d'avoir été aussi généreux sur ce
film tu sais très bien que je t'adore je
voudrais dire merci à tous les gens qui
ont travaillé sur ce film
les techniciens les producteurs tout le
monde et tous les acteurs surtout son
vous j'aurais jamais joué comme ça donc
merci
jérémy leurs champs d'or alma fanny
benjamin tout le monde j'en oublie plein
mais vous savez très bon voila merci à
ma famille à mes petits frères à mes
parents j'espère que vous êtes fier de
moi et voilà et et à mon mec aussi c'est
ce qui est plus cool au monde de ta
copine voilà merci